[Music]
so my name is Matteo chic today I will
describe for you do a new gradient
boosting libraries like GPM and CAD
boost you might notice that in the title
there is a question and if you know the
better Aegis law of headlines usually
you might suspect that the answer's no
however in this case actually you might
have good reasons to switch to light
beam or car booster ok so let's start
with a small introduction about me my
name is Matteo Sheik I'm currently data
scientist McKinsey and company here in
Warsaw in the past I used to work in
different places I used to work at CERN
I used to work at Max Planck Institute I
used to be also a software developer
currently I'm doing mostly machine
learning and my today's presentation
will be split into three parts firstly I
will tell you about the III boost the
theory standing behind the extra boost
how its implemented it's crucial because
those two new libraries that I want to
describe they take inspirations from
extra boost they're basically more or
less the same algorithm with small
improvements so then I will describe the
new algorithm the new libraries and in
the end I will show you benchmarks I
have a lot of them and why do I want to
cover those new libraries so first of
all although they are quite young there
already managed to be very successful in
Kangol competitions so for example IBM
already won the spellbound Russian
housing market contest CAD boost was in
the top of in stock card market basket
analysis and believe me those are
reading libraries moreover I use all of
those libraries in my work I know when
to use which of them and I'm not an
author of any of those so my comparison
will be fair at least I hope so
ok so let's start with the theory of
Britain boosting so I hope that you are
all familiar with decision tree
classifier and as you know decision
trees work very well with nonlinear data
the problem is that a single decision
tree can very easily over fit your data
set so here you have an example this
example comes from scikit-learn
documentation and you can see that if we
built a deep decision tree
it's very prone to outlying observations
so usually people deal with this problem
by building answer and also by using
multiple trees one of n symbols is
gradient boosting so here is a very nice
sketch of gradient boosting this is
something that you can implement if you
have a ready-to-go implementation of the
decision tree classifier in like half an
hour so what we do and let me grab the
pointer okay so we take our data I Y is
the dependent variable we feed a weak
learner so like a shallow decision tree
again then as shown on this example here
in the bottom we end up with some kind
of a model this is the square ridge line
on the on this image and we end up with
some kind of an error we call this error
residuals and what we do later we take
another model so for example here f2 and
we fit it to our residuals so only to
this part here and we repeated many
times so H excu the residual F is the
model and Y is our dependent variable
okay but this is not actually how
exhibits works it is a bit more
complicated and in order to explain it
to you I will follow a very nice
introduction by mr. t aki-chan it's
called introduction to boosted trees I
really recommend it to all of you so mr.
Jackie Chan is author of victory booth
and he firstly observes that well if you
have an objective for a classifier you
usually can split it into a training
loss and the regularization term so in
case for example if we have some kind of
elastic net model in training laws you
have some kind of square error and in
regularization term you have a sum of l1
l2 l2 penalty CN so here in order to
simplify a bit I will use the square
loss and there is one more assumption
that we will do so if we build K
regression trees in gradient boosting
each of the tree will have its own
regularization term which will be like
used only for this tree
okay so training the gradient boosting
is an iterative process here I will
describe the algorithm for decision
trees and final prediction is basically
the sum of the predictions of all the
trees here you can see it here so we
take the first prediction and then the
second prediction and so on and so on
and we end up with the final model so if
we take our formula here we can this is
our prediction here y hat the prediction
of the TIFF TIFF after the TIF tree we
can basically unroll this formula and
put here our first of all squared loss
and then the prediction of the last but
one model and the current model so using
the formula of small multiplication we
can unroll it further moreover some of
the things here will be constant so for
example the Y square this is not
something we can really optimize because
those are our examples our observations
so they learned here an important
observation here is that you can use any
loss that you want as long as it is
differentiable so in our case it's mean
squared error and square loss here but
if you use tale or approximate
approximation you can take the first and
the second derivative here I will simply
simplify my formulas to use G&H letters
it will make the phoniest simpler and
after we remove contest constants we end
up with something like this yeah so here
I simply put those terms and change them
to GNH one thing that is left here is
the regularization term we still have no
idea what is our regularization term so
let's check what is it so in order to
understand the regularization on
decision trees in gradient boosting we
need to provide a notion for the tree
and so in our case the tree will be a
set of Leafs
each leaf will have its own weight you
can also call it a score it's a real
number and you have also a function that
for each observation tells you in which
leaf it ends okay so Q is the function
and W are the weights or score
so the regularization in extra boost
this term is basically the sum of l2 l1
and the number of leaves penalties and
now you might notice that thus here you
can see some Greek letters and basically
if you ever used 60 both those are the
parameters that you said so this is the
lamp that he said this is the alpha that
he said and this is the gamma then you
said in extra boost on the next slide I
will skip the l1 penalty because the
absolute value makes it slightly
slightly tough to write down all the
other optimizations of this formula so
let's come back to the full formula well
we have both the loss yeah and the
regularization term nothing changed here
we sum over all of the observations here
we sum over all of the leaves here each
leaf has its own l2 penalty I mean the
way it is here basically so then we can
change it slightly the order of some ink
and end up with something like this okay
and we can simplify it a bit further
using other letters so now we will use
uppercase G and uppercase H and if you
have a fixed tree now it's where the
magic begins so if the tree is set this
is constant this is constant and you end
up with a quadratic function yeah where
this is the variable 2w so then you can
optimize it you can say what is the best
value for your for your leaf for the
weight of the leaf and basically this is
what you end up with and the most
important fact this is something that
will be the conclusion of this part is
that in gradient boosting on decision
trees like it's implemented in each
boost you do not use entropy or
information gain for splits in a
decision tree but you use this gain so
what does it represent so here is the
optimal weight of the current leaf that
is not yet split here you have the
weight of the possible left zone of the
spit and here you have weight optimal
weight of the possible writes on here
and sorry those are like the estimations
and here you have additional penalty if
you
regularization term so now you can
easily say which of the splits are good
which of the speeds are not good
sometimes it might happen that none of
the speeds are good that actually you
should end up with this leaf and not
split further if you want to implement
this what do you do you sort all of the
attributes and then you linearly
basically pass through all the possible
values of split and compute the gain
okay so end of maths and what are some
other tricks that I implement an extra
boost to make it faster to make it
better so first of all when you build a
tree in extra boost you try to build
whole levels of the tree in the same
time it's done because as I told you
when you compute those gains you need to
pre sort all of your attributes if you
build the whole level in the same time
it can sort only once moreover you can
sort features before one of the levels
and then cache the result of sorting and
use it while building the next level
additional thing that is implemented in
English rebus is the shrinkage param
sinkage regularization so this is
actually something that this I would say
borrowed from gradient descent when you
have when you do gradient descent you
want to very slowly go to the tree or
minimum so if you put this shrinkage
parameter in here actually boost it will
kind of follow the idea from the
gradient descent and this prevents
overfitting obviously there are some
things that I did not cover about extra
boost so first of all exhibits offers a
GPU implementation that is sometimes
faster on large datasets one of the
libraries I will describe soon also
offers a GPU implementations of like GPM
other thing is that XG boost is very
well optimized for parallel and
distributed computations but it's
probably something you know well ok so
let's start talking about the new
libraries in so firstly I will describe
like GBM its allied GBM this is the
library that comes from Microsoft the
aim was to make gradient boosting on
decision trees faster and how did they
achieve that so the idea is that instead
of checking all of the splits
while you while you basically want to
create new leaves you check only some of
them so before they built a tree they
sort all of the attributes and then
bucket the observations they create bins
here and when they want to split a leaf
in the tree they do not iterate over all
of the Leafs but over all of the buckets
so there is much smaller number of
splits considered inch time another
thing is that once you switch to this
bucket implementation it's actually
called histogram implementation by the
authors you can very easily improve your
optimization techniques for space data
and as you know if you do some kind of
one hotel encoding often most of the
data is sparse that most of the data
that we deal with then in light BM
actually the trees are not grown in this
very first fashion where you try to
build the whole levels in the same time
they try to optimize that a bit and they
built first if the leaf that provides
the biggest difference in the loss one
more import important thing here is that
extra boost already has the histogram
method implemented it's not by default
so if you want to use it you need to
switch the tree method parameter to hist
okay the other library that I would love
to present to you is can boost it's
developed by Yandex it's a very fresh
library the first release was September
14th they had a different idea instead
of making it faster they wanted to
prevent overfitting as you know gradient
boosting can from time to time over
fritz
despite the regularization techniques
that you have there and how did they
achieve there so first of all they they
they have more sophisticated handling of
categorical variables but also they
notice that in gradient boosting you
have and thing that is called the
gradient bias so they ran a very small
experiment that that is shown on this
chart so they basically created this
distribution that they can sample from
they took a sample single sample and
trained their model
boost like model on it and this is
represented by the solid blue line and
you have the mean squared error on the
y-axis then they decided to do a similar
training procedure but on each iteration
so for each tree in the experiment they
sampled a new dataset from the
distribution so it's like if they had
infinite data set so it's obvious that
such such examples like algorithm will
perform better because simply the
training set is larger and it does not
catch any noise from the data so the
authors of CAD boost find found out how
to improve over XG boosts if you have
just a single data set and they build an
algorithm that maybe not fully fight
this gradient bias so it does not fully
fight the problem with the correlation
between your model and the noise but it
at least approximated the perfect
solution how do they do that so first of
all they use a data structure that is
called oblivious trees oblivious tree is
decision tree where on each level all of
the splits are the same so in the normal
distribution a tree all of this piece
can be different in oblivious tree is
not true and the second thing is that
for each tree before they train it they
randomly permute all of the observations
and therefore each of the observations
if they compute the gradient they
computed only on the preceding samples
okay so those are the main things that
are improved in hand boost so let me now
switch to benchmarks so we want to
compare all of the free libraries
firstly I will show you some of the
benchmarks done by different people not
by me this is the benchmark don't buy
one of the bloggers of the bloggers and
she compared like GPM and actually boost
she compared them in terms of the time
of execution so what you can see here
this small blue field here is the time
spent by like GBM and this brown field
is the time spent on the exhibit on the
borsch data set one of the caracal
competitions
and on the x-axis you have number of
frets you can easily tell that exhibit
is sorry that light GBM is much faster
one important thing here to note is that
it should boost implementation he did
not use the histogram method so it
compares with the original extra boost
so as you can see the speed-up is
sometimes twelve thirteen times so this
training time well usually prediction is
much faster than training here and here
you have an perspective of authors of
exhibit library after they implemented
the histogram method they compared it to
the histogram method of light GBM and
here is the a you see here the AUC
scores of both methods as you can see
they are very similar scores the only
interesting difference is in case of the
higgs-boson dataset where the method
that is guided by the loss of by the
maximum difference in the loss in light
GPM they perform better than the
original extra boost algorithm they also
compared the execution times of
histogram method energy boost and light
JVM and first of all they usually take
the similar amount of time but the still
datasets usually datasets with large
number of parameters well like GBM is
much faster and this is the example of
vehicle learning to rank dataset and
then there is benchmarked on bike add
boosts developers they compare lock loss
on different datasets and they claim
that their algorithm is better than all
of the others all of the datasets a very
important thing here to notice is that
if you have default parameters in CAD
boost so for all of these parameters
when they say that something isn't it
steamed with by a.cian optimization and
they use like five thousand iterations
five thousand five thousand threes in
their experiments the important thing is
that default parameters of cut was
usually outperform tuned versions of
like GPM and extra boost
so the point is that usually I do not
trust benchmarks I only trust my own
benchmarks so I decided to prepare one I
took the Amazon data set from the cat
paws experiment the problem of this data
set is that it contains only categorical
variables or even worse it contains only
IDs the features are basically IDs so we
do have to do some kind of one hood
encoding in order to work on top of this
however in the experiment nothing like
this was done and I also did by a.cian
optimization with a smaller number of
iterations on my machine and I and I
compared few things I compared you see
the training time and the prediction
time so as you can see in terms of a you
see CAD pose is the best but only if you
manually specify to it which of the
features are categorical otherwise it
does not perform this what light GBM has
a similar feature you can manually tell
it which of the features and categorical
are divided unfortunately the AUC score
was worse and then for the training time
this is unfortunately the biggest
disadvantage of Cadmus it's much much
slower you can see here that for example
the cat pose with categorical variables
preeminence light beam takes two seconds
which means that basically you can do
quite well optimization of
hyperparameters applied JVM before your
first iteration of cat boost and the
training phase yeah and like GBM is
faster than it was here I did not use
the histogram implementation of each
boost and then the prediction time so
this is very interesting let G be and
here is slower than an extra boost the
fastest cat boost but only if you do not
choose the categorical features and
there is a very good reason behind this
because as I told you in candle they use
oblivious trees and they can do much
more optimization there if you are
interested further in this I can explain
after the lecture
and one more thing here importance that
all of those libraries have very nice
scikit-learn wrappers so they are very
easy to use okay so it's time for the
summer
so I would suggest a few things for you
for all of you that use gradient
boosting in your work
first of all try caddos from time to
time as it can improve your scores but
maybe even more important switch to
light GPM or the histogram
implementation in examples if you do a
lot of rounds of your gradient boosting
so for example if you do feature
selection if you do hyper optimization
of the parameters yeah then you can save
a lot of time and one thing that I
learned while I was preparing the
materials for this presentation is that
it's very useful to use biasing
optimization and well it's probably most
of you are not the word we currently
have a data science team here in Warsaw
we are growing we are looking for new
data scientists we have a very wide
variety of projects please join us at
our booth that is next to other sponsors
and we can talk a bit more about what we
do about what who are we looking for and
exciting a bit ok and here is the list
of the references my presentation is a
very blowing it up there is a link on
the bottom and I really recommend to you
reading first of all the introduction to
boost the trees by Yankee John and if
you want some more details on CAD pose
there is a publication that is called I
hope I put it here
yes fighting biases with dynamic
boosting those are the two that I will
recommend most ok thank you very much
so any questions so to be honest I did
not use random search here so I cannot
tell you the absolute values if it was
like two or three times faster but from
my experience it can faster converge and
it basically will find you the minimum
yeah because the random search will
simply be somewhere close to the minimum
so I wouldn't say it's way better
I would slide this I would say the
slight improvement and obviously
gradient boosting is a different role
than you are networks because the models
are much simpler you basically have
decision trees instead of you know a
large number of mirrors at least give it
a try
so let me browse for them so my
benchmark was on top of Bayesian
optimization this one was at as well
here it doesn't really matter I mean
maybe the parameters have a very slight
connection with the time spent but
usually if you set the same depth and
the same number of iterations they will
have very comparable time performances
and here it was I'm not sure but
probably also by accion optimization I
would have to check this one actually
okay no more questions
thank you very much
[Applause]
you